well I think the short answer to that is
there's two two pieces to it one is to
maintain a robust set of educational
programs so that so that you have lots
of students who want to come to the
school but the second way frankly is
through the generosity of your alumni
that with the state budgets being being
cut as they are in Michigan and a number
of other places we found a few years
back that we were just not going to be
able to be within the top tier of the
schools competing with the people we
want to be competing with if we didn't
go out and raise a significant amount of
money from our alumni so we we started a
capital campaign probably five six years
ago which we just ended up and the
timing was was good for us obviously but
but we raised 362 million dollars
against a goal of 350 and so it's really
through the generosity of the alumni and
I think more and more is difficult as
fundraising maybe in an economically
difficult time like this for schools
like ours as we try to stay in the same
league with the with the private
institutions I think it's what the
alumni are going to be kind of support
that they're going to be providing so so
that is I think an increasingly
important part of the financial
structure of the school as as the state
support has has dwindled and you would
expect you could not form a viable
strategy around increase seeing that you
believing that state support was going
to be increasing in the future I think
it really is the alumni support and
we've been very fortunate that we've had
some terrific alumni help us with that
and and the second thing we did is we
really didn't have the physical plant
that would enable us to offer
educational programs in a way which
which had some economies of scale
associated with them and so as part of
our capital campaign and part of the
hundred million dollar gift from from
Steve Ross we just completed a two
hundred and seventy thousand square foot
facility which came
line a couple months ago so so we now
have a great physical plant in Ann Arbor
that allows us to do things in a very
efficient way while we're still under
taking the action based learning of
disbursing our student teams around the
globe which is a reasonably expensive
way of doing education so so I think the
the two big things were number one to
have have a really good physical plant
that allowed us to do things in an
efficient way and keep building the
Alumni relationships and kind of making
the case for alumni support and we're
very fortunate that we've had a great
history of people who've been very
committed to the school
in michigan our model is that we're
pretty decentralized operation so unlike
some public schools in which you would
have to get presidential approval for a
particular slot or the number of the
tenured faculty that's pretty much a
decision which is left to us says the
business school so we have to be able to
operate as an economically sound
institution but as long as we can do
that we can grow the faculty as we as we
wish so we are not in a mode where we're
saying okay what we're going to do is
decrease the number of tenured faculty
estate support comes down instead we're
looking at ways to probably increase the
size of some of our programs
particularly right now the demand for
our undergraduate business program is
extremely strong and while we were in a
constrained physical position over the
last couple years as we were under
construction we really had demand three
or 4x what are our supply was so what we
are trying to do is say all right is
there a way for us to adjust the size of
some of our programs so that we're able
to maintain a sustainable economic model
sitting underneath the school and for us
i think the the big benefit is that
we're extremely diversified school in
the sense of having both undergraduate
and an MBA program and a master's in
accounting program and also where we
have a lot of very strong demand for all
of our programs the program that is a
little bit chat of a challenge for us
these days is our evening mba program
which you know obviously is is very
geographically bound and historically
that had served the automotive companies
and now obviously with their economic
difficulties their tuition assistance
programs have declined and so as a
result our enrollments in our evening
mba program have declined but that's
about one-tenth of our overall overall
enrollment base so so what we try to do
is maintain a rope
a set of educational programs so that we
won't have to either cut the number of
faculty lines we have because it's
really important to be able to
continually bring in new new talent into
the school all the time so for this year
for example while we're expecting that
the state budget allocation to us
declines we'll be hiring six or seven
new faculty members right out of PhD
programs